trains are an integral part of almost
every major city on the planet
if you put them underground they become
metros above ground they become city
light rail
on the street level they're trans
between large cities they can become
high-speed rail
transporting up to 1300 people per train
at intervals up to a few minutes modern
day transport
does not get more economical than this
even electric cars have absolutely
nothing on a system like this
it's just so goddamn effective now if
your city lacks good public transport
what they need to do is build
infrastructure pictured here but what do
you do if the surface is too overcrowded
well then you
have to build underground rail usually
anyway
and so the city of las vegas decided to
take some transit tunnels
after all car traffic is a big problem
in las vegas and there's no good public
transportation
all the necessary work was done stations
are excavated tunnels were aboard
and so las vegas was ready for a system
able to move hundreds of thousands of
people each day in an effective and
environmentally friendly way
foreign
okay so i think we're past the point of
sarcasm so i'm just gonna drop it for
now
this picture right here this [ __ ]
picture right here summarizes
everything wrong not just with american
car culture and american public transit
but also this bizarre popular worship of
out-of-touch silicon valley billionaire
tech bros and just please consider for a
second
whom does this system really serve we
did all this tunneling we did all this
construction all this effort all this
money
so that a couple of teslas can drive
around in a tunnel where metro trains
could travel
holding up to a thousand people per
train set
but instead we have expensive sports
cars holding five
and even if the system was extended all
over las vegas
what would it really achieve it would
just be one more lane
but underground and gamer lines
and here i'd like to highlight just how
shallow the tech brain solution is for
problems
it's basically just throwing capacity at
it hey
does your city suffer from chronic car
dependency and all its associated
problems
such as noise pollution air pollution
heart disease obesity
oh and also constant traffic jams elon
musk goes
and either have a name for it an
infrared which just call the
more traffic lanes but the thing is
as humanity moves more into the cities
as urban populations skyrocket
we simply cannot allow everyone to just
drive cars whatever
there's just no space even if we build
out dozens of new highway lanes
underground
what happens once you get out of the
tunnel where do you put your car
especially in a city center
and at this point instead of trying to
hatch elaborate plans over
gigantic underground parking lot
complexes or the like you know more of
that tech brain
solution we could go for realistic
solutions such as
disincentivizing motor traffic in dense
urban settlements
because whether you like it or not while
electric cars are nicer than internal
combustion cars
they still have absolutely nothing on
trains
an electric train is the most
environmentally friendly mass transit we
currently have
and since that seems to be the best
solution for now why not just build more
of it
in tokyo the city where i took all these
pictures and videos the share of motor
transit
is 12 while public transportation share
is 51
and tokyo can achieve these numbers
because it has a vast
developed and dense public
transportation network you don't need a
car in tokyo
public transportation takes you
absolutely everywhere
in contrast in las vegas the share of
motor transit is
ninety percent that's nine in a zero
and public transportation is four
percent these are laughable numbers with
pedestrian traffic constituting just
one percent and so shouldn't las vegas
and american cities be doing the same
thing as japan
i mean it's not like they couldn't do it
they're the richest country on the
planet
but of course car culture is very very
difficult to change
and make no mistake it has to be changed
because it's completely unsustainable
and elon musk instead of trying to help
america transition away from cars
somewhat
just continues to pour more fuel on the
fire
and why wouldn't he he's an out-of-touch
car maker billionaire he doesn't care
about innovation
he doesn't care about the environment he
doesn't care about you
all he cares about is making as much
money as possible
and then on the side constructing his
own little private escape route to mars
should things on earth go to [ __ ]
because if they do and elon musk does
manage to put together his mars colony
i'm sorry to tell you but you will
not be on the evacuation spaceship the
top 1 percent will escape
you were rotten the toxic wasteland that
elon musk helped bring about
his utopia is not star trek it's blade
runner
but on the positive side the las vegas
loops well
inauguration seems to have finally made
a lot of people realize
that elon musk's [ __ ] projects are
just that
[ __ ] projects they're just elaborate
schemes so that elon musk can sell more
cars so he can get richer
and so he can build that mars colony so
that he can ditch earth should things go
south
i'll leave you with this clip from cnbc
of a reporter trying her absolute best
to sound excited
about a road tunnel it gave me a
significant amount of
secondhand embarrassment so i want you
to suffer with me
in the meantime please don't forget to
like and subscribe and i also have a
patreon if you think this content is
worth your money
links are in the description thank you
for watching and i'll be seeing you
next time as you descend the escalator
into the loop station
you see the tesla's waiting to whisk you
into a tunnel
43 feet below ground now you might think
all right it's like a subway
but this is more like a highway
underground
and because it's las vegas this is also
a thrill ride
the las vegas convention center loop is
part thrill ride
part light and sound show but mostly